there was a point when I tried to watch
like every other anime youtuber everyone
everyone in my sphere and then it just
got to a point when it just became like
stressful cuz you just watch other
youtubers it's like oh man I wanted to
do that topic or I wanted to do that
topic um and now like pretty much I just
keep up with what my mates are doing and
you know some other people yeah but like
did you yet guys ever go through that
phase as well I did but then like very
quickly I realized like just how again
like same enjoyable just how broad anime
youtubing is and how many topics the
work of it so like yeah yeah at that
time I was like oh man I wanted to do
that I do I went to that day but then
after a while I was just like [ __ ] it
people have already done this I'll
[ __ ] do it like I do my own twist on
it and I'm sure my wanting to enjoy it
and if they're you know if they're so
willing to be like oh this is just a
copy or so its own I'm just like well
the problem I was doing a video earlier
this year about things I'll never
understand about Japan and I was wait a
minute things I'll never understand
about Japan was about Ted and I was like
[ __ ] I'll never understand I still did
well yeah every watched money-you she
was excited from you too I think and I
never be worried about overlapping at
all cuz I was pretty confident that I
was doing the stupidest [ __ ] that was
available so I was like I was like no
one's is willing to embarrass themselves
as me so I'm pretty sure you were kind
of an anomaly I mean you were called the
93 percent for a reason you know
like when I please start when I started
YouTube mine was completely here's I'm
gonna try and repulsive punctuation and
this is just what I remember your old
Twitter bio because I do
I did all Twitter bio Rizzo how do you
remember it was like because I think I
remember click on it for some reason it
was like I'm that other fast-talking
British guy that not Yahtzee or
something because that was always my top
comment so I was I was just like let's
just let's just refer to this in the bio
but like the more I did videos I guess
more than my own style evolved cuz I
started YouTube 2007 so like mine was
that right like near the beginning of
YouTube so the one there wasn't really
anyone else to play off of so I just
kind of copied who I was watching at the
time and there wasn't many creators on
the platform but in terms of you guys
did you how did you find your style how
did you start out I guess I mean do you
almost feel that like YouTube style is
like you just try a bunch of things and
then one or two of them work and you
just like iterate it and then you try
again with a bunch of iterations of like
that thing that you did yourself not
copying other people but like so you
have a success with one thing then like
okay what worked about that how do I
then try and a bunch of new things and
slowly you shot to figure out okay this
isn't working this isn't working
I don't know wait what do you think cuz
you're just very different cuz I'll see
ya at British TV yeah yeah oh my god III
take inspiration from screen white as
well it might in my year in review year
interviews was directly influenced by
Charlie Brooker [ __ ] fantastic and
that is one of my key influences so
that's something I would have watched
yeah and then when I sat down front the
camera I thought that's why I want a
channel and it's when I'm on camera it's
kind of not made more like a kind of
more obviously energetic song a stick
bit yeah individual I'm not that
monstrous off cap well your style
sometimes it's almost like reminiscent
of like David Mitchell in terms of that
very like dry sarcasm you know that's
like it's just so beautiful I love David
Mitchell you know
yeah I'd like that but without the like
depressing look sometimes that David
Mitchell has I've been on a four-day
trip it's pretty depressing like sad
face who faces bridge TV's my main
influence I wouldn't say actually I've
been influenced by another YouTube
channel as such as a result but what I
have found is over the years I started
off quite strong in that character and I
lost it because I started going from
commentating on things in a room doing
more travel stuff library you can't be a
cynical sarcastic [ __ ] you have to
be nicer when you're out and about doing
things so I lost that but this year by
virtue of the virus by virtue of being
indoors mode can I come back to
rediscovering that character and who I
actually enjoy being on camera